well I just have to say it uh everybody
here in the studio has what I call
burnthal fever yep ladies very happy
that he stopped by but I gotta say this
he's a man's man yeah so the men uh very
pleased to have him here Eduardo yeah I
was I was impressed okay now tell us
what impressed you about John burnt
though very charismatic dude the veins
that stuck out of this guy's neck when
he was relaxed right right he's so
strong taught taught that he has just
veins protruding out of his neck and
it's just they're there I've never heard
I'm sorry I didn't know this was a thing
and I'm constantly uh my life has been a
series of humiliations obviously I'm
constantly hearing about aspects that a
dude that women like that a guy has and
I think wait we have to have that like I
knew oh we're supposed to have broad
shoulders and we're supposed to work out
and have arms and all these things that
I neglected to do but then when I hear
oh yeah he has veins in his neck okay
I'm sorry I don't have veins in my neck
we didn't know that time
okay not only do it maybe he's got high
blood pressure should we be worried
about it right no no he doesn't not only
do I not have neck veins that show I
might not even have veins in my neck you
know what you know I'm with you on this
yeah
um I went and had an MRI recently they
found no veins in my body they said the
blood is just sloshing around Loosely
they did they said I was technically
more jellyfish than man he said I'm a
big bag a six foot four bag and stuff is
slashing around inside and then John
Bernthal comes in here with actual veins
yeah and suddenly I'm the loser well do
you think John Bernthal would compare
himself to a jellyfish the things that
you say sometimes it's like come on dude
okay well so I understand I'm no burn
thaw I get it I was impressed too I
really like the guy a lot uh and you
know that's a guy I want him at my side
when the apocalypse comes yeah because
I've seen him in action in all these
different shows that he's done and all
these different roles that he's done
this guy knows how to handle himself
he's the real deal he's the real deal I
want him at my side my friends now who I
love I love my friends they've been my
friends for like 30 years yeah but you
know that like Rodman Greg if trouble
breaks out
all three of us are going to faint at
the same time you're gonna paint and
then what are you gonna how are you
gonna like how are you gonna contribute
to society like a sitcom yeah with no
cameras yeah there'll be no cameras left
and no actors and the three of us will
be in the woods making something kind of
arch and witty uh and and we'll say this
is what we have to and then
three like three arrows go into US
simultaneously and uh oh my God we're
eating we're eating our protein is
robbed from our bodies my thing is that
yeah he's I saw Eduardo uh blay I saw
you gazing at him you know get in here
blay and Blake you were the one who to
be fair said John Bernthal is
before he showed up and I'm trying to
psych myself up for the interview he
said you know what I love him he's so
the opposite of you Conan why would you
say that uh well you know I love his
work obviously uh oh so that's why he's
the opposite of Me no but I will say and
I don't I'm trying to think of a way to
say this that's not gonna come off just
go fat just go for it he's got such like
first of all he's also very funny yeah
very chill cool energy He Just Smiles at
you and your your chest just opens up
now I'm not saying around you that I'm
not always on my guard and you give off
this energy that maybe is it's like
being your high voltage lines yeah yeah
I felt just like I was just melted
didn't it like just being around him he
just hints did say if they were gonna do
a remake of twins they would do it with
you and John burn so instead of
Schwarzenegger and Davido yeah John
burntall would be the Schwarzenegger and
I would be the DeVito that's correct
yeah okay well I don't take that as an
insult at all I admire DeVito a great I
think he's a terrific performer and
actor and I'd be happy to fill his shoes
completely agree I just think it's so so
I am what you're saying is that I give
off an electrical charge that makes you
tense and right now you're clinching
your whole body is clenching I'm nervous
you're gonna like I know you're I'm out
of Arm's Reach but I'm still nervous
you're gonna come around the table hold
on I'm trying to see if I could reach
you no I can't I'm nervous
no I know exactly what you're talking
about we always look towards what we're
not and I'm like looking at John
Bernthal and I'm thinking yeah he's got
some groundedness that I don't have I'm
sure please God have this be true that
there are some qualities I have that
that John wishes he had
that's not happening right now is it no
very hard John's driving so hard driving
home right now John's driving home
thinking like there's no quality Conan
has that I want no no no but but what
I'm saying is I I do understand why
everyone here is smitten with John it's
the same thing with Goldblum there's an
otherworldly X Factor like he's yes
bernthal's got old school Hollywood
Charisma yes yes he does Yogi or even he
reminds me of Fred Ward do you remember
that actor that recently oh Reno
Williams strikes again actually no it's
Rhema Williams Adventure Continues okay
let's just oh my God I almost took my
own life right there wow I think of him
in the right stuff yes exactly drummers
Tremors yeah Tremors yeah great actors
oh yeah no he has that kind of he has
that kind of energy and you also see it
in rimo Williams here we go
it's not real
talk about it don't even joke about what
is it called it's called Rima Williams
Adventure Continues I think that's what
I said oh I saw what you said well
anyway he's in Tremors he's in right
stuff and uh Remo Williams one more time
passed a deadly spell okay fine but
let's just go back a little and correct
our errors here Remo Williams gets it
done every time it's fun we're having
fun okay let's let's take this seriously
okay I think what I thought was cool
about him I mean all the a lot of the
actors are like oh I had a theater
background and I went to like school for
it and stuff but then he comes and he's
like I got beat up by people I got beat
up I fought a lot of people and that's
just like that's just cool well can I
say something and I want to just stress
to our listeners I don't think one
should try to get beat up I just don't I
I think and sona's putting the message
out there to a lot of impressionable
young people listening cool to get just
beat up I didn't mean it like that but
you know what I mean you know that I've
been in many a scrape in my day you talk
about the one fight no no I've been in
countless because I can't remember them
all so many times I've woken up on a
floor with glass in my air no that's it
knows they smashed your nose in that's
the one fight you've you've been in
that's okay it wasn't even a fight and
it's gonna turn out later on I fell
asleep in front of an Acer computer I
remember
we fell on the keyboard you got a big
gash in your leg because I was carrying
trash and did somebody put a tune of
tune oh my God that doesn't count
say that story
I got punched once one time my mother
said you have to take out the trash I
was wearing shorts and someone had put a
tuna fish can in the trash bag and like
you do and it chunked up against my I
still have the scar there and I had
appendicitis
um and uh and I had shingles in one eye
these are so don't tell me I haven't
been in my share of scrapes do not know
the authentic title to Remo Williams
yeah
I've constantly
I've constantly been in this [ __ ]
constantly constantly been in the [ __ ]
and she goes in one eye yes I did so you
had shingle I had shingle in one eye and
tell me that wasn't the equivalent of
being in a massive prison brawl you know
I've gotten into it and I'll get into it
again God I'm a real a brawler a king
mixer once I use the once you see these
ham hocks coming your way you best find
cover that's what I say oh man I'm
getting the sign to rap more
intimidating than a Rhymer
that guy just rhymed we better get the
[ __ ] out of here
hey it worked for Ali that's all they
feared was his rhymes
all right
uh trust me I'm an amazing brawler let's
just leave it at that